in der tiermedizin wir haben immer noch
wir sind froh darüber unser staatsexamen
das heißt das ganze studium wird
reguliert über die die ärztliche
approbationsordnung und ist eben
deutschlandweit gleich um unsere
fakultät einzuordnen es gibt sieben
deutschsprachige fakultäten für
veterinärmedizin und wir sind die größte
deutschsprachige es gibt fünf in
deutschland einmal schweiz einmal
österreich wir haben pro jahr knapp 300
studienplätze die auch gerne genommen
werden also das zur einordnung dann
warum physiologie learning ganz einfach
deshalb mein chef der studiendekan ist
professor für uns in der physiologie und
er hat es ein kreativer mensch der gerne
die studierenden aktiviert wir haben
gesagt mensch da machen wir doch mal was
zusammen das ist eben zur einordnung
dann weitere einordnung der passive
studierende das ist das problem bei uns
in der vorklinik jahr vorklinik umfasst
die ersten zwei studienjahre wo es
tatsächlich um naturwissenschaftliche
grundlagenfächer geht es ging gestern im
anderen vortrag schon einmal darum mit
welcher vorstellungen gehen die
studierenden an das studium heran
bei uns ist oder mit welchen motivation
bei uns ist ja meine oma hatte bauernhof
gehabt und ich habe schon immer gerne
tiere gestreichelt und nicht mag tiere
und jetzt studiere ich tiermedizin so
dass man sich bei uns im studium ist es
medizin dass wir uns auch mit physik mit
chemie mit physiologie biochemie
anatomie sowieso im detail beschäftigen
müssen bleibt manchen ein bisschen
verborgen
und da kommt eben dann schon oft der
erste frust auch weil einfach die
stoffmenge enorm ist und bei uns ist so
dass es ändert sich was und gleichzeitig
findet einfach sehr viel auch aufgrund
der menge der studierenden also 300 ist
schon viel für uns
man findet einfach sehr viel im
klassischen vorlesungs stil statt
das heißt die studierenden gut da kracht
das männchen über den büchern zusammen
über der last da die sitzen in der
vorlesung werden berieselt schreiben
irgendwie was mit haben das buch da
machen was andere schlafen und sind so
in dieser passiv haltung
wir wollten sie ein bisschen aufregend
und haben eben ein wahlpflichtfach
konzipiert das heißt um die studierenden
haben die pflicht vorlesungen und müssen
bestimmte anzahl an wahlpflichtfächern
belegen um zu den prüfungen zugelassen
zu werden das heißt bei diesem
wahlpflichtfächern sind wir ganz frei in
der gestaltung und es kam uns natürlich
in diesem fall entgegen
wir haben es in der vorklinik
angesiedelt zehn semester war vor allem
das zweite semester waren auch ein paar
tausend vierten sind aber immer wieder
dabei vor allem zwei zähler
wir haben das immer ausgeschrieben für
16 teilnehmer teilnehmerinnen und 6 x
1,5 stunden präsenz und auch ein teil
eben online das ist der punkt mit der
digitalisierung
es geht einmal darum jetzt erst mal um
die lernziele und dann geht es um den
punkt wie haben wir denn die
studierenden aktiviert wir hatten einen
teil offensichtlicher lernziele und was
sich auch gestern schon mal angemerkt
hatte werden ein sogenanntes rissen
curriculum was war unser ziel auf einer
metaebene für die studierenden nämlich
diese aktivierung wir haben wir das
gemacht
die teilnehmerinnen für die war auch
ganz klar was machen wir hier die
teilnehmer innen kennen die rollen eines
tierarztes begibt so rollen beispiele
also rollenmodelle aus der medizin die
auch für die veterinärmedizin gelten sie
kennen die informationsquellen für
lernmaterialien
das war ein ganz wichtiger punkt weil es
ist tatsächlich nicht so dass die
studierenden zum beispiel die uni
bibliothek nutzen bei uns als die wissen
gar nicht wie viele e books sind dort
auch kostenlos zur verfügung müssen
nicht einmal nicht immer alle nur in die
bibliothek rennen sondern es gibt
tatsächlich e books die ich einfach
downloaden kann kostenlos wunderbar also
solche dinge neben unseren nudel
angebotenen dann die teilnehmerinnen
kennen das konzept inverted classroom
dieses konzept haben viele studierende
noch nicht gehört weil sie einfach noch
nicht damit in berührung gekommen sind
ein teil unseres wahlpflichtfachs ist
dann auch der entwertet classroom und es
ist so dass die dann zum beispiel
bestimmte videos anschauen tab talks wir
haben auch elektronische fallbeispiele
die dann schon durchgearbeitet werden
können
auch in der vorklinik damit also
patienten fällen
und wir diskutieren auch das konzept des
in wörth class für uns also die lernen
auch tatsächlich diesen begriff kennen
bei uns dann eben canon online angebote
und deren einschätzung da geht es auch
darum ich google einfach mal ich schau
mal was gibt's für onlineangebote wo ist
die quelle kann ich dieser quelle
vertrauen das ist ja auch ganz wichtiger
punkt stichwort medienkompetenz und auch
ein teil kennen die grundlagen des
lernens ja
damit hat bis dato der tiermedizin
studieren de der lernt so sage ich mal
vor sich hin versucht irgendwie alles zu
lesen wir haben ja auch gelernt nur weil
es einmal klick gemacht hat ist es noch
nicht gelernt sondern die übungen die
wiederholung gehört dazu ist ein großer
bestandteil
was waren unsere ziele für die
studierenden neben den offensichtlichen
lernzielen nämlich sie sollen sich aktiv
am unterricht beteiligen dann sie sollen
in gruppen zusammenarbeiten da komme ich
gleich dazu eine gruppenarbeit gehabt
über das ganze semester
sie sollen informationen sammeln und
ergebnisse präsentieren das heißt sie
müssen sich auch im team absprechen und
sie werden motiviert das waren unsere
ziele des so genannten hidden curriculum
was hier dargestellt
also nicht erschlagen lassen bitte durch
diese folie weil das ist quasi die haupt
folie
es geht eben darum wie haben wir es
geschafft unsere studierenden zu
aktivieren
bitte konzentrieren sie sich erstmal auf
diesen rahmen hier der die der mit den
erhobenen händen für die aktivierung
steht und zwar wir haben einmal ganz am
anfang die erwartung der studierenden
abgefragt und wir haben die auch ernst
genommen sie haben wir die ernst
genommen wir haben die auch
aufgeschrieben und haben die auch via
foto protokoll eingestellt unseren
moodle kurs und darüber gesprochen
da kamen dann so erwartungen wie er ich
brauche noch ein punkt um eben zur
prüfung zugelassen zu werden das war ein
paar mal der fall
oder auch tatsächlich zu den zielen die
wir hatten ich möchte online angebote
kennenlernen
und so weiter und wir haben dann ganz am
schluss dann nehme ich den schluss schon
vorweg dann das ergebnis sondern ein
output eingefangen und gesagt was nehmen
sie mit aus ihrem mal pflicht fach was
denn die haupterkenntnisse haben wir
auch wieder festgehalten und haben die
dann abgeglichen mit dem wir haben das
dann noch mal mitgebracht das wird mit
karteikarten sammeln lassen auf dem
flipchart haben das in der letzten
stunde noch mal mitgebrachten gesagt
dass man ihre erwartungen
das ist jetzt dabei rausgekommen wie
sehen sie das und um auch für uns ein
feedback zu bekommen jetzt zu den
einzelnen zusagen aktivierungs punkten
ja das keyboard gruppenarbeit ist schon
ein paar mal gefallen
das ist schwierig für die studierenden
ja wir haben zwar einen
ausschreibungstext geschrieben es ist
ein interaktives wahlpflichtfach wir
möchten aktiv mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten
jetzt haben schon mal viele überleben
dann ging's dann haben wir nach der
erwartungshaltung sagt er
es geht darum dass sie über das semester
eine gruppenarbeit anfertigen dann hat
man schon so die ersten zurückhaltung
gesehen
dann haben wir auch noch die
gruppeneinteilung vorgenommen es war
besonders fies und auch extra so dass
die sicher dass die auch mal in kontakt
kommen mit neuen studierenden ja weil
die sind meist man im zweiten semester
da kennt man so die prep kurs kurorte
das sind nur die fünf mit den arbeiten
eng zusammen und die anderen diese noch
so ein bisschen nebulös vorhanden und
wir haben einfach unter den stuhl haben
wir tatsächlich nummern geklebt hatten
dann die nummern in groß an den an den
wänden und haben gesagt okay jetzt
schauen sie doch mal unter den stuhl und
gehen sie mal hier zu ihrer nummer und
verknüpfen sie sich ja dann haben die
meisten irgendwie nummern ausgetauscht
wenn jetzt alle whatsapp hatten oder
e-mail-adressen und so kamen schon mal
auch ein erstes kennenlernen und die
erste aktivierung zustande nämlich sie
mussten tatsächlich aufstehen
die mussten wohin gehen
sie mussten mit anderen fremden personen
sprechen und sich austauschen das war
schon eine erste punkt aktivieren dann
kurz aufs inhaltliche zu gehen geht ja
auch um das thema e learning steckt ja
auch im titel das war so nicht was war
diese gruppenarbeit sie sollten über
dieses semester ein wiki aufbauen in
nudeln und sollte neben online angebote
aus dem bereich der veterinärmedizin
zusammentragen und zwar gute beispiele
schlechte beispiele und warum ist es gut
und darum ist es schlecht und natürlich
vor allem in diesem studienabschnitt
doppeln sich dann oft die angebote da
haben ja auch bewusst gesagt das macht
überhaupt nichts weil da sehen wir dann
auch was wird denn viel gesehen was wird
weniger gesehen und wir können das auch
kommentieren oder können auch bewusst
darauf eingehen wir hatten ihnen konkret
also wichtig ist bei diesen übungen es
ist auch ein teil vom methoden kasten
bei so anleitungen ganz konkrete angaben
wir haben gesagt so vier gruppen
sie haben in der letzten stunde das ist
ihre stunde haben auch explizit so
kommuniziert das ist ihre stunde die
gestalten sie sie haben pro gruppe zehn
minuten zur verfügung heisst sie müssen
sich auch wirklich auf diese zehn
minuten beschränken sie müssen überlegen
stellt jeder von ihnen was vorstellt
einer was vor da mussten sie sich auch
im team strukturieren
das war ja auch ein teil der des hätten
curriculums für die studierenden dann
ein punkt hier unten haben sie
vielleicht schon sehen können ängste
ansprechen warum steht es da drauf weil
tatsächlich ein großer teil unserer
prüfungen nach wie vor mündlich
stattfindet und mein chef ist einer
dieser mündlichen prüfer im physikum im
bereich physiologie da gibt es nicht
viele mündliche prüfung
die wahrscheinlichkeit aus teilnehmer
sicht ist groß
der prüft mich vielleicht mündlich
erinnert sich daran habe ich angst etwas
falsches zu sagen und da an falschen
eindruck zu erwecken
ja das haben wir auch bewusst
angesprochen wie haben wir das gemacht
auch mit dem so genannten ziele bis das
mache ich auch immer in meinen seminaren
und habe es dort auch gezeigt so lipp es
ist so der rahmen wie laufen diese
seminare ab was ist wichtig und da habe
ich dann immer viel kärtchen die ich
dann auch wirklich an klebe die auch
jedes mal im raum kleben und der eine
punkt ist kam auch gestern immer mal
wieder fehler ist mein freund und wir zu
den studierenden sagen sie dürfen hier
fehler machen sie dürfen falsches sagen
weil aus fehlern lernen sie die war das
ist so der zentrale punkt der nächste
punkt ist die mitarbeit ja dass wir auch
bewusst wirklich gesagt haben uns ist
wichtig dass sie hier mitarbeiten weil
sie zusammen dann zum beispiel auch
dieses wiki aufbauen das ist ja dann
auch für die kommilitoninnen und
kommilitonen klar sichtbar da die
mitarbeiter die zusammenarbeit haben wir
da auch noch mal explizit erwähnt hier
über die gruppenarbeit schon vorgegeben
ist und ein vierter punkt den ich sehr
schön findet der begriff marktplatz da
zucken niemals denken sich harris will
jetzt da noch mit marktplatz haben wir
schon gruppenarbeit was soll jetzt das
und das ist einfach so dass ja auch da
verschiedene zum beispiel plattformen
lernen die studierenden kennen oder auch
wenn es ums thema lernen geht
verschiedene lernmöglichkeiten und es
ist ein marktplatz an ideen dieses
wahlpflichtfach und sie können dann
selber sagen ach mensch das sagt mir zu
das papier ich aus dass damit kann ich
jetzt weniger anfangen das ist alles ein
angebot und kann muss wie wenn ich auf
dem marktplatz geben vielfältiges
angebot habe und sagte heute nämlich die
ananas und die mango morgen nehme ich
den pfirsich und die kiwis
und das ist eben das was ich sehr
mächtig finde auch um in diesen methoden
kasten zu bleiben diese lernatmosphäre
zu schaffen
das ist nicht meine erfindung das habe
ich mir abgeschaut bei profile cool und
in der trainerausbildung
ja und das haben wir gemerkt ist sehr
mächtig weil wir auch merken haben
anfangen einfach gerade weil da steht
der studiendekan der ist professor ist
potenzieller prüfer ja das ist eine
respektsperson innerhalb der fakultät
da es am anfang schon zurückhaltung da
einfach aufgrund sei also qua amtes
wegen die mit gegeben dann wir wollten
ja die aktivierung weiter vorantreiben
ein punkt der hier steht es melden
erleichtern
da sitzen die 16 teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer erst mal ein bisschen
eingeschüchtert
da wissen zwar ihn wird gesagt hey durch
die fehler machen ihr sollt mitarbeiten
es gibt gruppen arbeiten und so ihr
braucht braucht euch nicht verstecken
und gleichzeitig am anfang seine
zurückhaltung dann gibt es ganz einfache
möglichkeiten zur auflockerung auch alle
methoden kassen hinterlegt habe ich mir
auch abgeschaut einfach mal sagt wer von
ihnen hat denn heute schon einen kaffee
getrunken keiner genau
doch und da das ist ein ganz einfacher
psychologischer trick jetzt haben sich
schon ein paar also man muss dann so
fragen nehmen wo die wahrscheinlichkeit
sehr hoch ist dass sich leute melden man
kann auch sagen wer von ihnen hat heute
schon einen tee getrunken ja ich melde
mich selber mit ich hebe den armen durch
die spiegelneurone
wird es den teilnehmenden erleichtert
auch den arm zu heben und wenn man
solche fragen ehe einbringt dann haben
sie sich schon mal einmal gemeldet und
morgen da passiert mir jetzt gar nichts
und es erleichtert tatsächlich das
melden
ein weiterer punkt sind auch die nur mit
gruppen das ist auch immer wieder
vorgedrungen dass man sagt man eine
fragestellung wenn jetzt an zeit geben
hatten wir auch als vortragender ist
meine zeit wahrnehmung anders als als
teilnehmer das heißt ich muss wirklich
wenn ich eine frage stelle mindestens
langsam bis drei zählen das überhaupt
die frage angekommen es verstanden das
wird darüber nachgedacht eine antwort
formuliert wenn ich lange genug warten
ich merke da kommt nix dann kann ich
immer noch diese murmel gruppe hinter
her schalten sagen unterhalten sie sich
mal mit ihrem nachbarn haben eine minute
zeit zwei minuten und dann stelle ich
die frage noch mal und dann kommt eine
antwort warum weil diese murmel gruppe
eine gewisse anonymität bietet da muss
nicht ich sagen als einzelner ja meiner
meinung nach ist es so und so sondern da
sage ich wir haben darüber gesprochen
wir sind der ansicht dass das nimmt so
die last von meinen schultern
da muss nicht ich allein die
verantwortung für das tragen was ich
dann eine traube vor der gruppe zu sagen
dass die präsentation weg das macht ein
weiterer punkt der dort auch dann zu
finden ist ist das thema blitzlichtern
das hatte ich auch schon erwähnt dass
man einfach eine kurze frage stellt
kurze abfrage macht und sagt eben was
nehmen sie heute mit damit am damm geht
bei jedem durch dann ist es auch wichtig
foto protokoll und das ernst nehmen
heißt ich notiere mir mit wenn die was
sagen oder ich schreibe auf kärtchen und
hengst hin wir fotografieren abgestellt
sind moodle ein dass wirklich der kurs
ablauf für die studierenden da ist und
das ist dann auch eine erinnerung und
sie sehen auch ihre meinung
abgebildet oder wenn wir zum beispiel
sagen ja schreiben sie es auf dann ist
auch die eigene handschrift hinterlegt
und das ist auch eine wertschätzung zu
sagen das wird ernst genommen
wir diskutieren auch über lehrmethoden
ja wir diskutieren auch zum beispiel
über dieses inverted klassischen konzept
stellen das erst vor und sagen dann was
halten sie denn so davon haben sie sogar
schon mal erlebt vielleicht in der
schule und nehmen das auf und sagen auch
weil wir viel wir haben eine neue
prüfungs und studienordnungen auf den
markt gebracht über die letzten drei
jahre
wo auch das inverted klassen konzept
erleichtert wird und wir geben dann auch
die transparenz und sagen das sind
unsere überlegungen wir möchten das
gerne so und so verankern was halten sie
davon oder wenn die ideen kommen nehmen
wir die auf und geben die auch an die
lernten weiter das sagen wir auch so er
will veranstalten regelmäßig retreats
mit unseren dozierenden wo es dann auch
um die etablierung neuer ideen geht
genau das heißt das ist auch wichtig um
eben diese wertschätzung zu bringen
dann holen wir feedback ein nicht nur am
also am ganz am ende der veranstaltung
sondern zwischendurch hole mir immer
wieder feedback ein entweder implizit
dass wir auch merken kiwi arbeiten die
studierenden mit das ist auch ein
feedback für mich als als dozent als
auch explizit dass wir sagen okay wie
hat ihnen heute zum beispiel die
vorstellung der tecdax gefallen oder wie
hat ihnen denn diese plattform gefallen
die sie als hausaufgabe bearbeitet haben
und wir sammeln dann ton contra oder
dass wir sagen wir sind jetzt negative
aspekt daran was hat ihnen nicht
gefallen
was würde ihnen da noch fehlen was
würden sie sich wünschen ergänzen dazu
und das halten wir eben auch wieder fest
als genau auch als wertschätzung weil
wir das wirklich ernst
dann ist hier noch ein punkt offen das
sind nur beispiele die sogenannte pohl
abfrage das kam ja auch immer mal wieder
auch schon als aktivierende methode da
sich frage stellt fragen stellen zu den
studierenden sagt hier ist 100 prozent
zustimmung hier ist 0 prozent zustimmung
und da kann ich dann auch eben sagen ja
zum beispiel so was wie ich bin heute
motiviert am albrecht fach teilzunehmen
die sind dann auch ehrlich und gehen
dann auch mal so auf die mitte dann kann
man sagen mensch was war heute los
da hab ich muss eigentlich für ein
testat lernen okay dann nimmt man auch
denn wie sozusagen die tagesform ernst
man muss dazu sagen das wahlpflichtfach
war freitagnachmittag ja und da hat man
dann auch wieder bewegungen und kann
dann aufs thema einstimmen in dem man
dann zum beispiel anschließt und sagt
wer von ihnen hat schon mal einen tab
talk gehört oder kann mit dem begriff
was anfangen und dann kann ich da gleich
studierende heranziehen ein paar kennen
das und sagen
erklären sie sich doch mal kurz und da
sind nie gleich auch ein bisschen in die
lehre mit eingebunden und wir sind
aktiviert genau schon immer wieder
erwähnt und aus meiner sicht für sehr
gut befunden es lohnt sich rein zu
schauen
in den münchner methoden kasten von
sprachraum wo ich auch diese methoden
heraus gezogen habe und es lohnt sich
die bewusst anzuwenden
sie erinnern sich an den studierenden
der vorher ganz blass das weiße männchen
über den büchern eingeknickt war
wir haben es geschafft dass unsere
studierenden tatsächlich auch
aufgestanden sind ja auch physisch
aufgestanden sind in unserem fach und
dass die bunt wurden die sind in
erscheinung getreten sie haben mit
diskutiert sie haben setzt sich auch
sehr kritisch geäußert was wir auch
wertgeschätzt haben und die haben wir
haben wir das geschafft wir haben sie
tatsächlich motiviert über das haben wir
auch schon mehrfach jetzt gehört die sie
in wain
sie hatten ein autonomie erleben also
die sie durften selber mitwirken durften
sich auch themen im rahmen der
gruppenarbeit zb aussuchen
sie waren sozial eingebunden durch die
gruppenarbeit ja und sie hatten einen
kompetenz erleben indem wir ihre
meinungen ernst genommen haben
wertgeschätzt haben und da auch wirklich
sehr gute diskussionen geführt haben
über die lehrkonzepte so genau hier
diesen gang haben wir gemacht wir haben
sehr positives feedback von den
studierenden bekommen
in der rückfrage über den kurs
interessant war die leute das war
tatsächlich 23 die gesagt haben ja ich
brauch noch ein punkt dass ich mich fürs
physikum anmelden kann haben dann gesagt
zum einem jahr sie haben den punkt
willkommen und sie haben so viel
mitgenommen und waren wirklich total
motiviert also sie haben das dann auch
zurückgenommen dass sie gesagt haben
nicht nur wegen dem punkt sind sie froh
da zu sein sondern weil sie tatsächlich
viel mitgenommen haben
der titeltrack juli wurde erfüllt was
wir uns vorgenommen haben und wir haben
sehr positive lernatmosphäre geschaffen
also am anfang von dieser doch ja
zurückhaltung ist es wirklich so ernst
gemeint darf ich da was sagen bis hin zu
wirklich von anfang an lebendiger
diskussion das hat man auch schon
gemerkt wie haben sie auch weiter
vorgesetzt kamen ganz anders rhein haben
gleich begrüßt und sind nicht so als
wenn jetzt hier richtig ja also das war
wirklich sehr schön zu sehen und das ist
meine take home message methoden einsatz
gezielter methoden einsatz und eine
echte interaktion das heißt das heißt
echte interaktion
es muss authentisch sein der methoden
einsatz muss passen zu dem was vermittle
ich was mache ich hier gerade der
methoden einsatz muss auch zu mir passen
damit es nicht liegt das merken die
studierenden das damit erreichen sie da
nicht viel
und eben dazu möchte ich ermuntern ich
freue mich jetzt über fragen anmerkungen
kritische anmerkungen weitere ideen ja
vielleicht sind transfer in andere
fachbereiche und bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit